devops certifications are the passport
to a successful career in the ever
evolving world of technology they
validate your expertise in essential
devops practices tools and principles
these certifications not only boost your
credibility but also open doors to a
cretive job opportunities with salaries
reaching up to
$18,000 per year in the United States in
this video we will be discussing top
four devop certifications that you must
enroll if you actually want to gain
knowledge and make a successful career
in the devops field the topics that we
will be covering are first why devops
then skills of devops professionals and
then the top certifications for devops
stay tuned till the end of this video if
you want to have a look at those
certifications also before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now let's start
with the first topic which is why devops
so in 2024 devops is more important than
ever because it helps teams work
together smoothly making software
development and it operations faster and
more efficient think of it as teamwork
for technology with the world relying on
Digital Services we need to deliver
software quickly and reliably devops
make this happen by bringing development
and ID operation closer they communicate
better share ideas and use tools to
automate tasks this means fewer errors
faster fixes and happier customers
learning devops in 2024 is necessary
because it offers numerous benefits in
the rapidly evolving Tech landscape
firstly devops practices enable
organization to deliver software faster
ensuring they stay competitive in the
market secondly devops Fosters
collaboration and communication between
development and operation teams leading
to improved efficiency and reduced
errors thirdly automation plays a
crucial role in devops allowing teams to
streamline process and focus on
Innovation fourth devop skills are
highly sought after by employers
providing excellent career opportunities
all right so this was about why devops
now let's have a look at the skills of
devops professional so being a devops
professional requires a diverse set of
technical skills to bridge the gap
between development and operations here
are some of the skills of devops
professional first containerization
Mastery of containerization Technology
ol such as Docker is essential
containers make it easy to package and
deploy applications consistently across
different environments next is orchest
isation tools Proficiency in container
orchester isation tools like kubernets
is important these tools manage the
deployment scaling and maintenance of
containerized applications next is
scripting and coding skills Proficiency
in scripting languages like python Ruby
or shell scripting is crucial devops
professional often write scripts to
automate tasks and processes Version
Control understanding and using Version
Control Systems like git is essential it
helps track changes in code and
collaborate effectively with team
members next is continuous integration
and continuous deployment that is cicd
knowledge of cicd tools like Jenkins
Travis Ci or Circle CI is key these
tools automate buildings testing and
deploying software ensuring rapid and
reliable releases next is cloud
platforms expertise in Cloud platforms
like AWS Azure or Google cloud is
essential for scalable and flexible
infrastructure management so this was
about the skills of a devops
professional now let's discuss the
certifications that is the top
certifications so the first
certification on the list is
professional certificate program in
cloud computing and devops the
cloud computing and devops offered by
simply learn is an exciting opportunity
for anyone looking to gain valuable
skills and tools in the world of cloud
computing and devops this course is in
partnership with en ICT Academy I guti
this comprehensive program covers a wide
range of technical skills and tools that
are in high demand in the IT industry it
combines the power of cloud computing
with efficiency of devops to create a
well-rounded skill set in this course
you will learn about Cloud platforms
like AWS and Azure which are the
backbone of modern it infrastructure you
will discover how to deploy and manage
applications on these platforms ensuring
scalability and cost efficiency this is
AK to mastering the tools that
Architects use to construct sturdy and
adaptable buildings the devops component
of the program equips you with essential
skills such as continuous integration
and continuous deployment cicd
automation containerization with Docker
and configuration management with tools
like anci it's like having a toolkit
that streamlines the software
development and deployment process
making it faster and more reliable by
completing this program you will be well
prepared to excel in roles where cloud
computing and devops expertise are
essential it's a pathway to promising
career and a chance to become a
proficient in the skills and tools that
are shaping the future of the IT
industry all right so this was about
professional certificate program in
cloud computing and devops now coming to
the next one that is devops engineer
Masters program so introducing our
devops engineer training Masters program
your gateway into a thriving career in
devops Technologies this comprehensive
course equips you with the technical
skills and tools essential for deploying
managing and monitoring Cloud
applications in this devops engineer
course you will delve into the
deployment methodologies cicd pipelines
all while mastering a robust arsenal of
devops tools such as git Docker Jenkins
and more think of it as a toolbox packed
with the latest most powerful ful
equipment for your Tech Journey our
program offers 120 plus live classes
instructor-led online classes ensuring
you learn directly from the industry
experts Additionally you will gain
access to 90 Plus hours of high quality
e-learning real life case studies
chapter and quizzes and simulation exams
making your learning experience rich and
handsome but it doesn't stop there
you'll also become a part of Vibrant
Community moderated by devops expert
where you can share insights and grow
together so if you are ready to embark
on a career in devops do enroll for this
program so this was about devops
engineers Masters program now coming to
the next certification that is
postgraduate program in devops so this
postgraduate program in devops is a
dynamic collaboration with Caltech ctme
designed to elevate your skills and
align you with the industry benchmarks
this program is your gateway to a world
of opportunities where you will gain
expertise through our Innovative Blended
learning approach this course offers
live online devop certification classes
that are complemented by immersive
interactive Labs these Hands-On Labs
provide you with the real world
experience setting you on the path to
earning a prestigious scal Tech ctme
postgraduate certificate enrolling in
simply learns devop scol also grants you
access to our exclusive job assist
program facilitating your transition
into the professional World Additionally
you will work on 20 plus life I repeat
Additionally you will work on 20 plus
real life projects in integrated labs
and culminate your journey with a
Capstone project in three crucial
domains this course offers essential
skills including devops methodology
continuous integration and continuous
delivery configuration management and
containerization the best part is prior
work experience is not mandatory if you
hold a bachelor degree with an average
of 50% or higher marks whether from a
programming or non-programming
background you're eligible to join the
transformative learning experience
so this was about this postgraduate
program in devops now let's move on and
have a look at the next certification of
devops that is azure devops Solutions
expert embark on a transformative
Journey towards becoming an industry
ready professional with the Azure devop
Solutions expert Masters program this
comprehensive course is your gateway to
a flourishing career in the dynamic
cloud and devops Industry in this
program or in this certification you
will Master the art of work working
smarter collaborating efficiently and
delivering faster results using The
Cutting Edge array of modern development
services you will be armed with the
Knowledge and Skills that employers in
the industry truly value what sets this
program apart is the industry recognized
certification you will earn upon
successful completion a testament to
your expertise so for all the courses
that we have now discussed you will get
a certification for that all right now
what makes this learning experience
exceptional is the opportunity to learn
from leading industry experts who have
created the course content to ensure a
directly applicability in the real world
you'll not only gain knowledge but also
work on the Practical projects backed by
our network of Industry partners and
their Career Services job assistance
Services personalized CV building career
Affairs and interview preparation make
your transition into roles like Azure
pipeline aure container aure storage
smoother whether you're a fresh graduate
eager to make your mark or a
professional looking to Pivot into the
exciting field of cloud security this
program opened doors to a world of
possibilities in the cloud and devops
Landscape so this was about the Azure
devops Solutions explor as you explore
the vast landscape of devops and cloud
computing certifications remember that
your journey towards expertise is a
professional one each certifications
like I gu professional certificate in
cloud computing and devops devops
engineer Masters program postgraduate PR
programming devops and Azure devop
solution expert offers a unique path to
earning your skills whichever you choose
know that your commitment to learning
and growth will open doors to a world of
opportunities in this exciting and
evolving field all right guys with that
we have come to the end of this video If
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up I hope it really help you all
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to no
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here